Welcome to Sun Springs retirement community have the time of your life for the rest of your life
- We've got everything you could ever need...over a hundred clubs.  So what brings you to Sun Springs?
- I'm just here to die.
Hi, moving in?  I was hoping you'd be a man.  There's not enough erections around here as it is.
What's this?  You were a cheerleader? My mother was very sick though so I quit the team.
Maybe you should give it another shot
We want to start a cheerleading Club.
Who will you be cheering for?  Ourselves.
Show us what you got.
i always wanted to be a Cheerleader
We could do with a little help
We want you to be our prayer. The oldest category is 18 plus we're 18 plus 18 plus 50
I'm not gonna lie to you
It's gonna be a lot tougher than I thought why not jump too much. I get this I had my knee replaced
Did I mention I had some idiot? Yeah, you did along with the shocking amount of other information
Martha what about you me? No, I'm fine. I'm bit as a bill
What did we tell a dime you were dying yesterday and you're gonna be dying next week in the meantime
Should be dancing your ass
Humiliate yourself !
Can't do this. We're all so worried about what everyone else is thinking
When of course the only thing that really matters is what we think of ourselves
- Break a hip
- Get pregnant
I always wanted to date a cheerleader
Now I know you're scared I'm scared too, but there's one I practically out there
- I've never had a grandma before and now it's like I have eight
- You're one of us now except with higher boobies